it occurred in here but not aware but
you should know that we have a more
pressing matter to dealing with the
election is work what the [ __ ] ah thank
you you're back good you'll want to hear
this just feels as bad as it looks I'm
afraid dammit this never should have
happened me you better we knew better
and still we let our guards down oh I'll
admit even I am having a hard time it's
agreeing with you marrow is dead I know
but we've got bigger problems right now
okay the four went absolutely berserk he
wounded bizarra tried to kill me and
then he fled very killed I know that
lunatic couldn't be trusted oh it's true
I'm afraid Cicero was a little whirl
with flashing this place yeah I can't
even concentrate that was funny what
time don't forget the ranting and raving
about the night mother how she was the
true leader of the Dark Brotherhood and
Astrid with Justin for ten
look we've got to deal with this
situation I want you to find that
miserable little fool and end his life
but first find my husband make sure he's
all right after the attack on John flew
into a rage when Cicero left on John
went after him they disappeared into the
wild search Cicero's room maybe there's
something in there that shed some light
on where he might look we've got to deal
with this situation you've got to be a
lot of evaluation okay with the server
that guys [ __ ] that kick case now get
thing hit that dire right there you
gonna [ __ ] nutcase I read it well
then I say let me to doubt all right
where's that [ __ ]
have you found something yeah Sarah
Sarah good does it say where the dot
nevermind every moment count find on
beyond and then and that gestures
twisted little soul to the void in as
many pieces huh the old shadow there I
like [ __ ] out there that [ __ ] thought
here
our weekend oh [ __ ]
okay so much [ __ ] flows like all the
other horses I don't think this guy
could die though honey
should've figured Astrid would send you
what gave it ya gotta admit them in
there through the door some old safe all
right but I slashed him good pretty sure
i severed an artery don't know what
you're gonna find in there but you can
probably just follow the blood siren has
[Music]
time to get Skyrim in her people let's
say you in your defense they can't spend
a second sign right so be okay
[ __ ] gas stuck my dick okay where's
that crazy
back
Oh
yeah [ __ ] out that [ __ ] [ __ ]
madam you caught me I surrender forget
that
oh I like that very good very good
creative but killing me would be a
mistake oh yes it would displease our
mother walk away they're only pretend
rashes that you did the job and
strangled round for what [ __ ] in a lot
yeah
buzz earth
and
ok Sarah cookware
what's up five
chances
shadow moon shadow mantle as a shuttle
where does and he's swinging from a rope
that he can't gotta say the heart I got
here comes a shadow we're on Jonas XO
tell you what and now that this cicero
mess has been mopped up we can get back
to the matter at hand there's just one
more target before we strike out at the
Emperor have you by chance heard of the
goal the goal neck Festus has been seen
heading this part of their curation plan